à travers de petites touches d'acrylique
muriel gare saint tin des paysages c'est
cheney viennent à commencer par le
dessin avant de prendre le pinceau
la peinture c'est quelque chose où
j'essaie de transmettre des ambiances
j'aime beaucoup voyagé ça c'est une de
mes passions donc souvent c'est des
impressions de voyage des couleurs qui
représente la magie des paysages que je
vois
comme muriel très autres artistes
exposent au carré à la farine un
collectif d'amateurs avertis qui se
prépare depuis trois ans
[Musique]
chacun est libre d'y exposer ce qui lui
plaît en fait je laisse toujours les
artistes aussi bientôt des expositions
que de photos est libre d'exposer ce
qu'ils ont envie d'exposer et je pense
que déjà quand quelqu'un a envie
d'exposer je pense que ça garantit déjà
une certaine qualité artistique
soto tic soi-même en fait et voilà
et j'aime pas du tout imposer des thèmes
sculptures peintures ou photographier
les styles se mélangent abstrait ou
figuratif ici l'art se découvre sous
toutes ses variations
[Musique]